CAPOEIRA [inaudible]
DAWALY.
FURTADO.
JONES.
LABOR YOU'RE MY WIRE
[inaudible]
MY NAME [inaudible]
OUR LUCK [inaudible]
CAN [inaudible]
RALPH.
SKINNER STERN STONE.
AMBER WHY KASKI.
WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
THE SECRETARY NOTICES THE
PRESENCE OF A QUORUM OF LIKE TO
WELCOME.
EVERYONE TO I THINK I'VE SAID
THE LAST COUPLE OF TIMES TO THE
FINAL BUDGET HEARING OF THE YEAR.
BUT I THINK -- THIS TIME IT
REALLY WILL BE FINAL THANK YOU
TODAY WE'RE GONNA HEAR ONE BILL
THE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
TREE RUBIO.
AGAIN WHICH IS THE FINAL TRAILER
BILL ASSOCIATE WITH THE CURRENT
BUDGET PACKAGE.
AFTER TODAY'S HEARING A B. ONE
OH ONE WILL BE ELIGIBLE TO BE
TAKEN UP ON THE FLOOR COLLEAGUES
THIS AFTERNOON.
PRIOR TO STARTING IT'S IT'S NO
TIME LIKE YOU KNOW THE LAST
HEARING OF THE EAR TO HAVE TWO
NEW MEMBERS JOIN US.
WE WANT TO WELCOME -- TO SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE SENATOR DOLLY
INCOME A YEAR AGO WELCOME TO THE
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
WITH THAT MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
ANY REMARKS FROM YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU -- GOOD AFTERNOON
FINANCE WERE PREPARED TO HEAR
FROM YOU ALL ON A B..
ONE OH ONE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THE KEY ITEMS IN THIS BILL ARE
REGARDING HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS.
ON HOUSING THIS BILL ALLOCATES
ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN TOTAL SPENDING TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS.
AND HOMELESSNESS -- THE OVERALL
BUDGET PACKAGE THAT WAS AGREED
TO BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE INVESTS A
BILLION DOLLARS IN HOMELESSNESS --
SERVICES AND PREVENTION OF WHICH
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS IN THIS BILL AND I'LL
BRIEFLY GO THROUGH BOTH OF THOSE
ITEMS.
ON THE HOUSING PACKAGE THIS BILL
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN PLANNING AND
PRODUCTION GRANTS FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
THIS IS SPLIT BETWEEN A ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AND ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR REGIONAL EFFORTS.
AND ALSO INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE INFO
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM AND
THAT INCLUDES OVERALL SET ASIDE
OF ABOUT NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
US PARTICULARLY FOR COUNTIES
WITH LESS THAN A QUARTER MILLION
PEOPLE.
THERE'S ALSO A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO CAL HFA FOR
MIXED INCOME LOAN PROGRAM.
AND FINALLY FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO EXPAND THE USE OF THE
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION TO THIS PROGRAM TO
ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN SPENDING FOR HOUSING
SUPPORTS.
THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES A PLAN
FOR BONUS POINTS FOR
JURISDICTIONS WITH PRO HOUSING
POLICIES AND WONDER APPLYING FOR
DISCRETIONARY GRANTS -- AND
THESE INCLUDE PROGRAMS LIKE
TRANSFORMERS CLIMATE COMMUNITIES
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
AND THE AFTER MENTIONED IT'S
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM.
IT ALSO INCLUDES SOME CHANGES
FOR THE LOCAL HOUSING TRUST FUND
MAKING MATCHING GRANTS AVAILABLE
TO NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES -- AS
WELL AS SUPPORT FOR MORE
BUILDING OF AUXILIARY DRUGS WILL
DO ALL IN YOUR HEAD CITIES ARE
SECONDARY OFTEN KNOWN AS GRANNY
FLATS -- TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY
OF HOUSING.
WHEN IT COMES TO HOMELESSNESS
THE OVERALL BUDGET AMOUNT IS SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND WE KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF NEGOTIATION BETWEEN MEMBERS
OF THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE AND WHAT'S WITH THE
STAFF?
AND THE ALLOCATION THAT IS IN
THIS BILL IS TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR WHAT'S
KNOWN AS THE BIG THIRTEEN THESE
AR CITIES -- WITH AN ADDITION --
THESE ARE CITIES WITH ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
AND POPULATION -- IN ADDITION TO
THAT THERE'S ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
COUNTIES ONE HUNDRED NINETY NINE
DOLLARS FOR A CONTINUUM OF CARE
THESE ARE KNOWN AS CEO SEES
THEIR DESIGNATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
FOR MORE REGIONAL EFFORTS.
AND FINALLY TEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO BE PROGRAMMED AT A FUTURE
DATE.
IN ADDITION TO THOSE FUNDS THIS
BILL ALSO EXPANDS THE ELIGIBLE
USE OF FUNDS -- AND MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW JURISDICTIONS
ATTACKED THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
THEY MAKE IT EASIER TO BUILD LOW
BARRIER NAVIGATION CENTERS
INCLUDING EXPANDING THE USE UP
BY RIGHT -- BUILDING -- AND AS
WELL -- EXTENDING THE DEADLINE
FOR THE AUDIT OF THE COMMITTEE
BASED TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PROGRAM THIS WAS PREVIOUSLY VIEW
AND NOW WILL BE AN AUDIT.
AND THEN THE FINAL PACKAGE PART
OF THIS PACKAGE THAT I WANT TO
MENTION IS WITH REGARD TO HAVE
REMEDIES FOR JURISDICTIONS THAT
DON'T MEET THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT
AS REQUIRED BY LAW.
OF COURSE THE ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO WORK WITH JURISDICTIONS
IN HOPES THAT EVERY JURISDICTION
THAT IS NOT IN COMPLIANCE CAN
COME INTO COMPLIANCE. FOR THOSE
JURISDICTIONS THAT DON'T BUT
THEY DON'T PLAN TO ME -- MEET
THOSE PLANNING AND ZONING
TARGETS -- THERE WILL BE UNDER
THIS BILL I NOTICE AND TWO
CONVERSATIONS EITHER IN PERSON
OR OVER THE PHONE WITH THAT
JURISDICTION TO TRY TO BRING
THEM INTO COMPLIANCE.
ONLY AFTER THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND THAT DUE PROCESS WHATEVER
FOR ALL BE MADE TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE FOR A LAWSUIT.
AGAINST I. JURISDICTION IF THAT
LAWSUIT TAKES PLACE AND IF IT IS
SUCCESSFUL AND THE JUDGE RULES
THAT THE JURISDICTION IS NOT IN
COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING STATE
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW.
AT THAT POINT THE JUDGE WOULD
HAVE TO ISSUE A SEPARATE ORDER
SAYING THAT THE JURISDICTION
MUST COME INTO COMPLIANCE AND
THE JURISDICTION WOULD HAVE A
FULL YEAR TO DO SO.
ONLY AFTER THAT FOR YOUR LAPSED
AND THE JURISDICTION IS STILL
NOT IN COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING
LAW AT THAT DATE WHAT FINDS BE
IMPOSED ON THAT JURISDICTION
THESE WOULD BE BETWEEN TEN
THOUSAND AND A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS -- AND THEN IF THE
JURISDICTION CONTINUES NOT TO
COME INTO COMPLIANCE AFTER THAT
THERE ARE SOME ADDITIONAL
REMEDIES -- DEFINES COULD BE
INCREASED AND FINALLY AS A LAST
RESORT WITHIN THE DISCRETION OF
THE COURT -- AND AGING OF THE
COURT MAY BE APPOINTED TO HELP
BRING THAT JURISDICTION INTO
COMPLIANCE SO I KNOW THIS HAS
BEEN THE PRODUCT OF A LOT OF
PRODUCTIVE NEGOTIATION
CONVERSATION WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND LEGISLATIVE
STAFF.
AS WE APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO
WORK WITH YOU AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS ON ANY ELEMENT OF THIS
PACKAGE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER DALI.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- SO AS
SOME OF YOU SAT ON A MORE
SUPERVISORS FOR SIXTEEN YEARS
ENDED.
GENERAL PLAN AMENDMENTS AND SO.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
COMPLIANCE PART FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT ARE IN COMPLIANCE
AND AND YOU KNOW THAT.
IF YOU HAVE A GENERAL PLAN THAT
IS IN CONFORMANCE AND YOU DON'T
MEET YOUR HOUSING -- ELEMENT
IT'S QUITE FRANKLY 99% THE TIME
IT'S DUE TO THE FACT THAT.
DEVELOPERS ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF THIS IS THAT THE PLAN THE
GENERAL PLAN OPTIONS BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO GET A
RETURN ON THEIR INVESTMENT AND
THAT SO I'VE I'VE RAN THE TRAP
LINE ON QUITE A FEW OF THE
COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT.
AND THE COST IS SO HIGH THAT
THERE'S TOO MUCH RISK AND THAT'S
WHY WE DON'T SEE A LOT OF HOUSES
BUILT QUITE FRANKLY IN.
ALL OF CALIFORNIA SO NOW WE'RE
GONNA GO IN AND AND COMPOUND
THAT EVEN MORE SO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO RAISE TAXES TO PAY
EVEN FIND SUED -- IF IF THEY'RE
GONNA COME IN.
AND I KNOW YOU'E TRYING.
TO COURAGE THEM ALONG.
THROUGH WITH THE PROCESS THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT I I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY.
IF YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO BUILD
THOSE HOMES NOW -- INTEL WE
DRIVE THE COST OF THOSE HOMES
DOWN -- SOMEHOW -- YOU'RE NOT
GONNA GET MORE HOMES WERE GONNA
BE THE SAME THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
NOT BUILDING HOSE AUS BECAUSE
DEVELOPERS -- THERE'S TOO BIG OF
A RISK AND THEY DON'T GET A
RETURN ON THEIR INVESTMENT.
SO I IT'S LIKE CONTINUE TO GO
AFTER.
CITIES AND COUNTIES DON'T BUILD
HOUSES WE INCENTIVIZE YES HAT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA PUT MONEY
INTO SIN OF EYES -- HOUSING
WHICH IS -- IT WILL BE HELPFUL
IN DRIVING THAT COST DOWN BUT
THERE'S THAT MONEY'S COMING FROM
TAXPAYERS SO.
I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT
HAVING A HAMMER ON CITIES AND
COUNTIES -- BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE NOT THE REALLY THE ONES
THAT BUILD HOMES AS DEVELOPERS
TO BUILD HOMES.
I THINK I'LL MAKE A COUPLE BRIEF
POINTS IN MY COLLEAGUE DANIELLE
MAY WANT TO WEIGH IN AS WELL --
THE FIRST THING IS FOR THIS
SPECIFIC LAW THAT HOUSING
ELEMENT -- IT'S NOT REALLY
FOCUSED ON THAT PRODUCTION
ALTHOUGH THAT IS THE GOAL TO GET
THESE HOUSES.
BUILT IN THE AND OF COURSE
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT AND THIS IS
PART OF THAT BUT WHEN I SAY IT'S
NOT FOCUSED ON THAT THE
JURISDICTIONS DON'T ACTUALLY
HAVE.
TO PRODUCE THE HOUSES IN ORDER
TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW THIS IS
EVEN WELL BEFORE THAT IT SIMPLY.
PUTTING TOGETHER A PLAN AND
MAKING PLANNING AND ZONING
DECISIONS THAT ARE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH HOUSING ELEMENT LAWS SO
IT'S MUCH MORE BEFORE --
DEVELOPERS SAY HEY IT'S
EXPENSIVE TO BUILD YOUR END PART
OF THE LAW AND YOU MENTIONED
IT'S INCENTIVES AS WELL WITH THE
INFO INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM OFTEN DEVELOPERS DON'T
WANT TO BUILD BECAUSE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT THAT
BUILDING IS IN REALLY THERE SO
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
SUPPORT TEIR BUT THIS.
IS BEFORE THEN EXISTING LAW JUST
SAYING WHAT STATE HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW YOU SHOULD PUT
TOGETHER A PLAN AND EXCITING
DECISIONS THAT COMPLY WITH THAT
WHETHER DEVELOPERS ARE OTHERS
BUILD OR NOT.
AND THEN I THINK THE SECOND PART
IS YOU MENTIONED SOME THESE
JURISDICTIONS EVERYONE IS IN A
DIFFERENT SITUATION SO AS PART
OF THE REMEDIES INCLUDING THOSE
THAT ARE A LAST RESORT.
BUT THERE IS A PART OF THE BILL
THAT ALLOWS FOR MITIGATING
CIRCUMSTANCES OF JURISDICTION
DIDN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT IN THIS COMMITTEE ABOUT
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS IN ON
PARADISE.
THIS LAW IS NOT GOING TO BE
ENFORCED AGAINST THE COMMUNITY
LIKE THAT WHEN THEY'RE COMING
OUT OF THAT DISASTER LIKE THAT
SO THERE IS SOME DISCRETION FOR
THE JUDGE TO MAKE THOSE TYPES OF
DETERMINATIONS.
SO IS THERE ANY FUNDS AVAILABLE
ENTERED ACTUALLY HELP THEM.
WITH THEIR THEIR GENERAL PLAN
AMENDMENTS.
SO GENERALLY REVIEW THAT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S GOING TO LOCAL%
JURISDICTIONS AS PROVIDING THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE -- TO COME
UP WITH THESE PLANS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- IS
THERE ANY INTEGRATION WITH NO
PLACE LIKE HOME -- WE'RE TRYING
TO BUILD HOUSING WITH PROP TO
FIND SO I'M I'M WONDERING IF WE
CAN DO SOME BLENDING SO WE GET A
BONUS TO SOME OF THESE
COMMUNITIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL FRIEND OF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND NO
PLACE LIKE HOME FUNDS SHOULD BE
DEPLOYED THE SIDE.
THEY HAVE BEEN APPLIED UP MY
APOLOGIES -- THIS LATE LAST
SPRING AND THE USES ARE SIMILAR
TO SOME OF THESE OTHERS AND THEY
CAN BE USED N COMBINATION WITH
OTHER FUNDS -- TO BASICALLY
BUILD HOT HOUSING ENTRANCES FROM
HOUSING.
AND JUST FROM A ANOTHER QUESTION
DIFFERENT SUBJECT BUT JUST FROM
AN ECONOMIC STANDPOINT IF IF WE
KNOW THIS.
THE FUSION OF FUNDING IS
BECOMING AVAILABLE WITH THAT.
KEEP THE PRICE OF RAW LAND THESE
INFILL PROPERTIES WITH THAT KEEP
IT STABLE WOULD INCREASE IT
WOULD DECREASE IT BUT IT.
GIVE A LIKE I'M AN ECONOMIC
MODEL ON WHAT WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN.
SO YOU'RE TALKING SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THE EXISTING PRICE OF LAND
WITHOUT DEVELOPMENT ON IT RIGHT
IF I HAD SOME INSTILL PROPERTY
I'M THINKING IF THERE IS A STATE
PROGRAM COMING WITH SOME FINDING
I MIGHT WANT TO HOLD OUT FOR A
HIGHER PRICE.
SO I THINK THE WHAT WITH THE WAY
WE'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT THIS
IS BY -- RIGHT NOW IN A LOT OF
THESE WELL ON ON THIS LAND IT'S
NOT SIT SIMPLY NOT ZONED FOR
HOUSING.
SO YOU KNOW WHERE IS THAT ONE
SPECIFIC PROPERTY IF YOU ZONE IT
FOR ADDITIONAL USES ON IT COULD
POTENTIALLY INCREASE THE VALUE
OF THAT LAND BUT IT'S THE
OVERALL SUPPLY -- HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA IS INCREASED THAT
SHOULD IN ARGUE MAKE UP HOUSES
HOUSING MORE AFFORDABLE.
AND THEN -- MY LAST QUESTION --
WE KEEP HEARING ABOUT MORAN.
IT IS MARIN EXEMPTED.
SO I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S
ANYTHING IN THIS BILL BEFORE YOU
REGARDING MORAN.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S IN THE
SPILL.
THEY'RE ALWAYS SPECIAL.
THANK YOU MENTOR YOU'RE WELCOME
SIR STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- THING
MAN MR IS ONE OF THEM WHEN IT
JUST.
ASK YOU TO FLESH OUT THE
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE.
FRAMEWORK AND HELP US REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT.
WHAT SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE
MEANS VERSUS JUST TO RESTRICT
FRAME OR CAN YOU?
HELP ELABORATE YES SO THE WAY AT
THE ADMINISTRATION AND WORKING
WITH NUMBERS THE LEGISLATURE
THINKING ABOUT THIS IS WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT -- WE'RE
BRINGING JURISDICTIONS INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW -- BUT
WE ALSO WANT TO JURISDICTIONS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE WERE NOT
GOING THAT NICKEL AND DIME THEM
OR HIT THEM FOR EVERY LAST
VIOLATION WE WANT THEM TO COMPLY
AND THE PENALTIES ARE ONLY.
IF THEY NOT ONLY DON'T COMPLY
BUT AFTER A PERIOD OF AT LEAST
ONE TO ONE AND A HALF YEARS.
AFTER THE JUDGE ISSUES THEIR
FINAL ORDER THEY'RE STILL NOT IN
COMPLIANCE TO THE REASON WE USE
THE TERM SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE
IS WE WANNA JURISDICTIONS TO
KNOW THAT IF YOU ARE BASICALLY
DOING THE RIGHT THING YOU KNOW
MAYBE THERE'S A CERTAIN PARTY OR
PLANNED IT DOESN'T EXACTLY
ALIGNED.
WITH WHAT HCV HAD IMAGINED AT
THE OUTSET -- BUT THE COURT SEES
IT AS THEIR THEY'RE TRYING TO
FOLLOW THE LAW THERE MAKING A
GOOD FAITH EFFORT THAT THEY
HADN'T MADE BEFORE.
AND THAT BRINGS YOU INTO
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE WITH THE
LAW SO IT GOES BACK TO THAT
PURPOSE THAT WE WANT YOUR
SECTIONS TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
EVEN AT THE END OF THIS REMEDY
ACCORD ABOUT IMPOSED REMEDY WE
STILL WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE WORKING WITH THEM AND NOT
SIPLY FILING LAWSUITS AGAINST
THEM.
SO SO WHAT FACTORS PLAY INTO
THAT DETERMINATION THAT HAVE
SORT OF A GOOD FAITH EFFORT AT
AND DID EFFORTS TOWARDS THE UP
PLANNING UPDATE IT MEANS OR WHAT
WHAT FACTORS ARE IN THIS YEAR I
JUST WONDER WHAT THE COURTS
WOULD LOOK TO IN TERMS OF NOT
BEING.
TOTAL -- STRICT CONSTRUCTIONIST
ON EXACTLY WHAT MAKES SENSE.
SERVER.
THEY'RE THEY'RE I THINK THEY'RE
TWO THINGS TO NOTE ONE IS THAT
THE COURT WITH A LOOK AT AND SAY --
IS YOUR PATTERN OF BEHAVIOR
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT FROM
BEFORE YOU KNOW BECAUSE WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT WHY EVEN BRINGS --
THE LAWSUIT INTO PLACES ONLY
AFTER THESE TWO MEETINGS IT'S
AFTER A NOTICE DAN DIA TOURNEY
GENERAL FILES A LAWSUIT AND THEN
THERE'S A WHOLE COURT HEARING
BEFORE THE COURT IMPOSES ITS
JUDGMENT.
AND SO PRESUMABLY THINGS ARE
ONLY GETTING TO THAT POINT
BECAUSE THERE IS A PRETTY WIDE
GULF BETWEEN THE LAW AS
INTERPRETED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND DEVELOPMENT.
AND HOW THE JURISDICTION IS
ACTING SO IF THERE IS A BIG
SWITCH IN THE JURISDICTIONS
BEHAVIOR WITHIN THAT ONE YEAR
AFTER THE JUDGMENT IS ENTERED.
DAN YOU KNOW CERTAINLY COURT
WOULD LOOK AT THAT AS A BIG
FACTOR IN COMPLIANCE IN WHETHER
IT'S SUBSTANTIAL IS UP TO THE
DISCRETION OF THE COURT -- BUT
THEY WOULD BE WEIGHING THOSE
FACTORS AND THEN I THINK THE
SECOND IS THAT THE COURT IN
ASSESSING ANY PENALTIES AND I
KNOW WE DISCUSSED THIS BRIEFLY
WHAT LOOK AT ANY MITIGATING
CIRCUMSTANCES -- AND SO DOES
COULD BEAT IN TERMS OF THE
RESOURCES THE JURISDICTION HAS
ANY EXTERNAL EVENTS -- ANY
CHANGES THAT ARE HAPPENING THERE
SERVING ALL THESE FACTORS WAY
INTO WHAT THAT SUBSTANTIAL
COMPLIANCE STANDARD IS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US IN.
AS WE'VE ADDRESSED THE HOMELESS
SO OVER THE YEARS AND THERE BEEN
MANY BILLS THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
AND CONTINUE ON IS THERE
ANYTHING IN THIS PARTICULAR
LEGISLATION.
IT WOULD HELP DIRECT THE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL.
TOWARDS RESOURCE NOT JUST THE
HOUSING WHERE THEY CAN.
LIVE IN RESIDE SLEEP.
FIND SHELTER FROM THE STORMS.
BUT TO PUT THEMSELVES IN AN
EMPLOYABLE CATEGORY SO THEY CAN
BE SELF SUFFICIENT. TO DIRECT
THEM TOWARDS REHABILITATIVE
OPPORTUNITIES WHICH MANY OF THEM
NEED ALCOHOL SUBSTANCE ABUSE FOR
EXAMPLE.
I DON'T SEE MUCH FOCUS ON THE
LONG TERM SOLUTION THERE'S NOT
JUST TRYING.
TO KEEP BUILDING AND BUILDING
AND BUILDING TO KEEP UP WITH THE
POPULATION OF INCREASING NUMBERS
OF HOMELESS BUT IT ALSO HAS TO
DELVE INTO.
DEALING WITH THE ISSUES THAT
CAUSE THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO BE
HOMELESS AND HOPEFULLY GET MANY.
NOT. TO HAVETO BE IN THAT CLASS
OR CHOOSE TO BE IN THAT CLASS.
SO I WOULD MAKE TWO POINT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT IT'S NOT
SIMPLY ABOUT EXPANDING HOUSING
OPTIONS ALTHOUGH THAT IS A BIG
PART OF IT AND SO I THINK THERE
ARE TWO THINGS THAT THIS.
TALE AND THE BROADER BUDGET TO
FIRST TO SPECIFICALLY IN THIS
BILL.
WHEN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS
RELEASED IN JANUARY IT PROPOSED
NOT SIMPLY SHELTERS BUT ALSO
NAVIGATION CENTERS AND A FOCUS
ON PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
ALL ACROSS THAT SPECTRUM?
AND WHAT WE'VE DONE SINCE THEN
WORKING WITH AND RECEIVING
FEEDBACK FROM MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IS EXPANDING THE
NUMBER OF OPTIONS FOR WHICH THAT
MONEY CAN BE USED SO.
THAT WE'RE NOT CONTROLLING IT AT
THE STATE LEVEL LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WHAT A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY -- BUT THEY KNOW ON
THE GROUNDS CLOSEST TO THAT AND
WHERE THE NEEDS ARE AND HOW TO
MAKE SURE NOT ONLY THAT WE'RE
HELPING PEOPLE GET SHELTER BUT
THAT WE'RE MOVING AS MANY PEOPLE
AS WE CAN INTO PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND THEN
EVENTUALLY -- IN SOME CASES
WITHOUT NEEDING FURTHER STATE
SUPPORT SO THERE IS THAT
FLEXIBILITY WITHIN THE SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE DOLLARS IN
THIS BILL AND THEN THE SECOND
THING I'LL SAY AND NOT ALL THESE
ELEMENTS ARE WITHIN THE SPECIFIC
BILL BEFORE YOU -- BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES A WHOLE PERSON CARE
PILOTS AND A NUMBER OF IN A
RAPID RE HOUSING EFFORTS AT UC
AND CSU INFINITY COLLEGES
BECAUSE OF PEOPLE CAN GET
HOUSING THERE THEY GET THEIR
DEGREE IT'S LESS LIKELY THAT
THEY WILL.
BE IN HOUSING EMERGENCIES SO I
THINK YOU SEE A NUMBER OF
EFFORTS WITHIN THE BUDGET
INCLUDING ALSO RE ENTRY FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRANSITIONING OUT
OF A CORRECTIONAL FACILITY.
THAT WE THINK ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ATTACK THIS ISSUE
FROM ALL ANGLES BUT WILL THERE
BE ANY LEVEL.
OF ASSESSMENT FOR EXAMPLE THE
NAVIGATION CENTERS HAVE AN
ATTRACTION.
THAT TO ME.
BUT AT THAT NAVIGATION CENTER
WHICH IS A CENTRAL PLACE.
WOULD THERE BE ANY ASSESSMENT
CAPABILITY AT THAT CENTER WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY THE RESOURCES THE
MEANS THE POWER BUT TO ASSESS
THE NEEDS OF THAT INDIVIDUAL.
NOT JUST IN TERMS OF WHERE THEY
WOULD RESIDE.
BUT HOW THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE FOR THEMSELVES.
AND FIND RESOURCES FOR THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE WILL
THERE BE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES IN
THE NAVIGATION CENTERS.
I BELIEVE SO BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
PRESCRIBING THE FUNDING TO THAT
LEVEL OF DETAIL IN STATUTE IN
THIS BILL SO I BELIEVE THAT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WILL HAVE A
LOT OF FLEXIBILITY IN MAKING
THOSE TYPES OF DETERMINATIONS.
WELL IT'S A LITTLE LATE IN THE
GAME BUT I WOULD SUGGEST
VERBIAGE IN THE BILL.
THAT MONEY SHOULD.
OR ENCOURAGING LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO FOCUS ON THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL.
THIS CALL TO YOUR FOLLOWED BY
MISS SKINNER.
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR -- I JUST
WANTED -- TO TO THANK YOU FOR
THE THE STRUCTURE FOR THAT --
THAT HOUSING ELEMENT COMPLIANCE.
AND COURT REMEDIES -- INITIALLY
THERE WAS SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT
A MUCH MORE ONEROUS PENALTY AT
THE END WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE
STATE TO COME IN AND TAKE OVER
AND I THINK THAT.
CREATED SOME ANXIETY FOR MANY OF
US WHO COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT -- EVEN IF IT WAS
NEVER UTILIZE THE FACT THAT IT'S
THERE BECOMES A I I THINK A
CHALLENGE SINCE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
IN THE STATE ALL REPRESENT THE
SAME PEOPLE SO I I AM I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT.
THE STRUCTURE I ALSO APPRECIATE
THE ESCALATING NATURE OF THE
COMPLIANCE -- PENALTIES BECAUSE
WERE REALLY.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE FIRST
STEP.
IN PLANNING FOR HOUSING WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT WHETHER YOU'RE
PRODUCING IT OR NOT THIS IS
REALLY THEFIRST STEP WHICH IS
THE PLANNING STEP AND SO.
ON REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT AND
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT I I
COMMUNICATED THAT THERE ARE MANY
OF US THAT ARE THAT ARE -- MUCH
HAPPIER WITH THE WAY THAT IT'S
BEEN STRUCTURED THIS POINT I
SHOULD CLARIFY AN INTEREST OF
FULL TANSPARENCY THERE IS AS A
LAST RESORT AT THE END OF THIS
BILL.
THE COURT WITHIN ITS DISCRETION
COULD APPOINT AN AGENT OF THE
COURT.
TO HELP BRING THE JURISDICTION
COMPLIANCE BUT AS YOU NOTED IT
IS ONLY AFTER A SERIES OF STEPS --
WHERE EVERY EFFORT IS MADE TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE WITH OTHER
REMEDIES WELL AND IT'S ALSO IT'S
A IT'S A COURT?
IT'S A COURT INITIATED PROCESS
CORRECT YES AND ED ED.
APPOINTED BY THE COURT -- AND SO
THAT THE I THINK IS IS FOR
FURTHER REMOVES THE STATE FROM
THAT WHOLE.
THAT WHOLE FRAMEWORK
[inaudible]
THE SCANNER.
THANK YOU I MADAM CHAIR -- I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD BILL AND
THERE'S MOST ELEMENTS TIME VERY
VERY HAPPY WITH.
THERE IS ONE CONCERN THAT I HAVE
IN IN THE HOMELESSNESS SECTION.
WHERE WE PROVIDE THE FUNDING TO
THE CITIES?
AND THEN TO THE COUNTY AND TO
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE.
THE LANGUAGE IN -- THE SECTION
STARTING WITH -- STARTING WITH
PAGE.
FORTY FOUR LINES TWENTY FOUR ON
IT ADDRESSES -- BEING ABLE.
TO DEAL WITH IMMEDIATE HOMELESS
CHALLENGES.
BUT THEN THE LANGUAGE IN THOSE
LINES TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN IS EXPLICIT.
OF IT'S VERY SAD NERO THAT IT
NEEDS. TO MOVE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING AND SUPPORTING
THE F. EFFORTS OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES MEANING
THE HOMELESS FAMILIES.
SO THEN YOU GO ON TO PAGE.
FORTY SIX AND IN OUR LINE
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN SIXTEEN IT
REFERENCES THAT THE FUNDS CAN BE
USED FOR PREVENTION SO THAT
WOULD.
INDICATE SOMEONE WHO IS NOT YET
HOMELESS.
BUT THEN I GOES DOWN TO LINES
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
NINE THIRTY WHICH SEEMED TO
REFERENCE.
FEDERAL DEFINITIONS WHICH ARE
VERY NARROWLY CONSTRUED TO BE
ONLY PEOPLE WHO ARE ALREADY
HOMELESS OR WITHIN FOURTEEN DAYS
OF BECOMING HOMELESS.
SO THEN IF WE GO TO PAGE FORTY
SEVEN IT INDICATES THAT WE CAN
USE THE FUNDS. TO ADDRESS AND
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS INCLUDING
RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
MY CONCERN IS THAT BY THE NARROW
DEFINITION.
OF THAT YOU HAVE TO BE WITHIN
FOURTEEN DAYS OF BEING HOMELESS
THAT IT WOULD.
RESTRICT THE THE SEEM TO BE
CONTRADICTORY.
AND IT WOULD ONLY ALLOW.
A NEW ENTITY WHO IS APPLYING FOR
THESE FUNDS WHO WANTS.
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT TO PREVENT A
FAMILY FROM BECOMING HOMELESS.
TO ONLY PROVIDE THEM THAT
SUPPORT IF THEY'RE WITHIN
FOURTEEN DAYS.
OF BECOMING HOMELESS.
MOST FOLKS WHO ARE FACED WITH.
EITHER THE POTENTIAL FOR
ADDICTION OR EVEN EVICTION NO IT
BEFORE FOURTEEN DAYS.
AND A WINDOW OF FOURTEEN DAYS IS
A VERY SHORT WINDOW TO REALLY.
ASSIST.
AND PREVENT THEM FROM LOSING
THEIR HOME.
SO I I ASKED MY STAFF TO TAKE
THE BILL TO LEDGE COUNCIL TO SEE.
IF MY INTERPRETATION BECAUSE I
DIDN'T WANT IT AND LEDGE COUNCIL
SAYS YES IT SEEMS TO BE
CONTRADICTORY OR THEY MAY NOT
USE THAT LANGUAGE.
BUT RATHER THAT -- THAT CLEAR
FINDING LANGUAGE MIGHT BE
HELPFUL.
AND I REALIZED THAT WE WANT TO
PASS TODAY I'M HOPING THAT WE
CAN DO SOME CLEAN UP LANGUAGE
BECAUSE WHEN I READ THE BILL IT
SEEMS VERY CLEAR IN ITS INTENT.
THAT WE WANT TO GIVE PEOPLE
FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO USE
THE FINDING IF THEY SO CHOOSE TO
HELP PREVENT PEOPLE FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS.
AND WE MAY NEED WHAT WHAT I
ASKED LEDGE COUNCIL IS WHAT IS
THE SIMPLEST AMENDMENT.
THAT COULD MAKE SURE THAT THESE
ARE NOT AT ODDS.
AND I WANT TO RAISE THIS BECAUSE
NOT ONLY BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE.
WE HAVE THIS CLEAR INTENT I
DON'T WANT IT TO BE
CONTRADICTORY BUT EDITION ONLY
IF WE LOOK AT THE DATA. FOR THE
RISE IN HOMELESSNESS IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS.
AND WE'VE SEEN THESE JUNKS. 17%
OVER A PERIOD OF A YEAR JUST
BETWEEN SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
IN MANY OF OUR JURISDICTIONS
[inaudible]
THOSE PEOPLE.
THE DATA SHOWS.
ARE NOT MENTALLY ILL.
ARE NOT ADDICTED ADDICTED.
MANY HAVE FAMILIES.
ALL WERE HOUSED NEVER ON HOUSE
PRIOR.
ALL HAVE JOBS.
SO THESE ARE ALL PEOPLE THAT
FALL INTO THAT CATEGORY OF
FACING.
THAT UNEXPECTED EXPENSE WHICH
THEN LED THEM TO GET BEHIND ON
RENT POTENTIALLY AND NOW I'M
SPECULATING BUT THEY FACED AN
UNEXPECTED EXPENSE. FOR THEY
FOUND THEMSELVES WERE THERE
WHERE THEY WERE LIVING.
MAYBE THE PERSON WHOSE NAME WAS
ON THE LEASE LAUGHTER HAD TO
MOVE IN THEIR NAME WASN'T ON THE
LEASE AND SO THEN THEY DIDN'T
HAVE PROTECTIONS OR ANY NUMBER
OF OTHER THINGS.
THAT IF WE CAN INTERVENE.
BEFORE.
THERE ON THE STREET IS FAR FAR.
LESS RESOURCES TO KEEP THE HOUSE
AND WE KNOW THAT FOR EXAMPLE THE
MAYOR'S THE FOURTEEN MAYORS OF
THIRTEEN MAYORS ALL WROTE US A
LETTER SAYING THAT THEY WANTED.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO USE THIS
FOR EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
SO I'M BEING VERY CLEAR ABOUT IT
NOW.
BECAUSE I REALIZED EVERYONE
WANTS IS TO OFFER TO PASS IT
RIGHT NOW.
BUT I WANT THAT CLARIFIED AND I
WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO THE
LANGUAGE.
MAYBE IT'S RIGHT AFTER BREAK
ELEMENT THAT WOULD CLEAR ABOUT
THE WHAT CLEAR LANGUAGES YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR SO -- NO -- TIME
PERIOD BEYOND FOURTEEN DAYS I'M
HEARING TWO THINGS FROM YOU
RIGHT CLARIFICATION ABOUT WHO
WOULD APPLIES TO THE THE
EXISTING HOMELESS OR THOSE WHO
PUT IT THERE WILL BE.
HEY AND SEE WHAT MORE
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE DOLLARS
COULD APPLY TO BOTH CORRECT YES
AND THEN THE FOURTEEN DAYS.
I WOULD HAVE TO BE MORE IN
FOURTEEN DAYS SO.
AND WHEN I SAY THAT CLEARLY WE
DO WANT WE DON'T WANT IT
AVAILABLE TO ANYONE SO.
SO OBVIOUSLY THAT HAS TO BE SOME
NARROWED YES.
AND BUT WE JUST DON'T WANT TO BE
BECAUSE OUR ABILITY TO INTERVENE
FOR SOMEBODY WHO'S ABOUT TO BE.
ON THE STREET IN FOURTEEN DAYS
IS THERE A WINDOW YEAH.
GOT IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND SO WILL HAVE OFFLINE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT AND I
WILL MAKE SURE THAT THAT THAT
YOU WERE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THE
SPECIFIC ASK YES.
THANK YOU MOVING ON TO SENATOR
MCGUIRE FOLLOWED BY SEVEN TO
BAIL THEM TO REQUIRE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR HERE MORE
THAN WELCOME AND HERE I WAS JUST
GONNA ADDRESS AT THE VICE CHAIRS
ARE COMMON AND THAT'S IN REGARDS
TO THAT.
THE HOMELESS FINDS IN THAT
PLEASE CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG I
BELIEVE THE HOMELESS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
THE FORMER KEEP FUNDS IT'S THE
ONE TIME THE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION THAT WOULD BE PROGRAMS
AND THEY'RE EXTREMELY FLEXIBLE
SOLES GONNA SAY SO TOTALLY UP TO
THE JURISDICTION ABOUT HOW THEY
WANT TO BE IN THIS BAND.
THERE ARE -- BENCHMARKS IN THERE
ABOUT HOW IT SHOULD BE SPENT BUT
IT'S VERY BROAD -- IN ALLOWS UP --
IT UP TO THE JURISDICTION --
WHAT WORKS BEST FOR THE MOST
PART SO I I KNOW THERE IS SOME
CONCERN AND -- THERE'S A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY IN THAT WAY --
WORKING WITHIN THE FRAMEWORK
THAT IS PROVIDED THANKS FOR THE
CLARIFICATION CITY TO BAIL.
YES -- THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FOR THIS LENGTHY DOCUMENT -- I
WANTED -- TO ASHU -- IN TERMS OF
THE BUDGET HOW MANY HOUSING
UNITS WILL THE BILL PROVIDE.
DO YOU HAVE A NUMBER.
I DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE AN
ESTIMATE FOR THIS BILL BUT I
WILL CHECK -- WITH OUR FINEST
OKAY WE HAVE IS OUR ONE AND FIND
OUT IF YOU HAVE A BASE GOAL.
OF YOU KNOW LIKE MEASURING
PROGRESS HERE'S HOW MANY UNITS
WERE PLANNING.
TO ACCOMPLISH WHAT IS THE BASE
GOAL OKAY THEN -- THE SEARCH THE
AREA THAT I'M SPECIFICALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT A JUST SAY THIS.
I COULD.
IN LOOKING AT THE BILL VERY
CAREFULLY THIS MORNING -- THE
3250% -- LOW AN EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME CATEGORY.
THAT'S KIND OF THE SOFT SPOT ON
YOUR BILL OKAY I FEEL LIKE THE
HOMELESS PROGRAM WE DID A PRETTY
GOOD JOB.
WE PASSED THE MAIL PROPOSITION
TWO LAST YEAR -- WE WE PUT
SUBSTANTIAL FUNDS.
IN THIS BILL FOR THE HOMELESS
PROGRAMS.
WE'RE KEEPING IT FLEXIBLE WHICH
WE GIVE IN THOSE CITIES THE
COUNTIES -- CONTINUED KERR
PROGRAMS OF FUNDS WERE DOING
PRETTY GOOD THEN THE THE TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM -- THE EIGHTY TO
A HUNDRED AND 20% INCOME
CATEGORY.
WERE REALLY BE FED UP WITH THIS
BILL.
DID A GOOD JOB ON NOW BUT THE
AREA THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR ME.
IS THE THERE IS A SCANNER CENTER
SCANNER WAS TALKING ABOUT AND
THAT'S THE THE AT RISK TO
HOMELESS.
ALLEGORY.
AND I I THINK WE'RE NOT THERE
YET ON THIS BILL OKAY.
I I I DON'T SEE MUCH EMPHASIS IN
THIS BILL ON THAT CATEGORY
THAT'S THE THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
PER. 13250% -- THAT IT'S BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING -- SO ARE HAVING A NEED
FOR AS MUCH AS ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION UNITS SHORTAGE.
AND THESE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE FALLING INTO HOME WAS IN
FACT SACRAMENTAL RIGHT HERE.
LAST YEAR JUST NEAR YOUR ONE
YEAR THE YEAR WAS 19% INCREASE.
AND WE'RE GETTING SIMILAR
NUMBERS IN LOS ANGELES SAN JOSE
SAN FRANCISCO ALL THE
COMMUNITIES ARE HAVING THESE --
INCREASES.
IN THE HOMELESS AND IT'S THE
PEOPLE IN THIS CATEGORY.
THAT ARE FALLING INTO HOMELESS
AND THE QUESTION AS OF DO YOU
AGREE THAT WE SHOULD FOLLOW UP
WITH THIS BILL.
IN STUDYING WHAT WE COULD DO
WITH THAT CATEGORY WE NEED TO WE
NEED.
TO FOLLOW UP.
AND DEAL WITH THAT PARTICULAR
AREA OR ELSE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE --
MMHM WAY MORE HOMELESS SO PEOPLE.
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR AND
WE'RE GONNA KEEP FALLING BEHIND.
OF IT EVERY YEAR IN TERMS OF
TOTAL NUMBER OF HOMELESS PEOPLE
THAT WE HAVE IN IN CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU KNOW YOU KNOW I THINK
WE'RE DEALING WITH THE HOME WAS
THAT WE HAVE NOW GOOD BUT WHAT I
THINK WE'RE NOT RECOGNIZING THAT
WE'RE HAVING A TREND HERE.
THAT'S REALLY A BAD TREND IT'S
IT'S DANGEROUSLY BAD.
OF AND PART OF IT'S BECAUSE BY
THINGS LIKE THE THE CANCELLATION
OF THE DEED RESTRICTIONS THAT.
FEDERALLY SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
UNITS.
HAVE.
IN TERMS OF THE DEED
RESTRICTIONS THE THAT WERE
PLACED ON THE GENEROUS LIKE.
THIRTY FORTY FIFTY YEARS AGO
THAT ARE NOW EXPIRING.
AND SO NOW THESE UNITS ARE BEING
PRICED AT A MARKET RATE THE
RENTS ARE RIGHT RISEN -- THE THE
THE INCREASE WITH THE FAILURE OF
OF ANY KIND OF RENT CONTROL OR
IN WRITTEN RENT ISSUES.
HAS REALLY CAUSED.
A LARGE NUMBER OF RANTS TO GO UP
WHICH PUTS PUSHES PEOPLE OUT OF
THEIR UNITS.
QUITE FRANKLY -- THAT'S THE
CONSEQUENCE -- WE KNOW THIS IS
HAPPENING.
AND WE'RE SEEING THE NUMBERS THE
ALMOST COUNTS ARE JUST GOING UP
SPEC YOU KNOW JUST.
IN A IN A IN A CRISIS MODE
MANNER -- BUT IN THE BUDGET HERE.
THIS TRAILER BILL DOESN'T
RECOGNIZE.
OF THAT PARTICULAR FOR THAT
PARTICULAR.
CATEGORY I HONESTLY IT DOESN'T.
I MEAN IF YOU LOOK AT IT FROM A
TRUE STANDPOINT IT REALLY
DOESN'T SO CAN YOU CAN YOU OUT.
IF YOU COULD COMMENT ABOUT WHAT
WE HAVE TO DO NEXT.
YOU KNOW IF WE'RE GOING TO ADOPT
THIS THIS IS KIND OF A HALF HALF
THE GAME.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
THIS [inaudible]
CRISIS CATEGORY THAT WE HAVE CAN
YOU ADDRESS THAT WHAT THE
INTENTION OF THE THE GOVERNOR
THIS IS A ONE TIME BUDGET MAINLY.
COULD YOU ADDRESS CAN YOU DRESS
WHAT WHAT COMES NEXT SIR WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE LOOKED AT IN
THE FUTURE. TO ADDRESS THESE
THIS CRITICAL CRISIS THAT WE
HAVE.
YES TELL MAKE TWO POINTS THANK
YOU FOR THAT I THINK THE FIRST
IS THAT YOU ARE RIGHT THAT A
NUMBER OF THESE PROGRAMS --
FOLLOW A BROADER MORE MIXED
INCOME YOU KNOW UP TO A 120%
AREA MEDIAN INCOME -- PERCENTAGE --
AND WHEN IT COMES SPECIFICALLY
THOUGH TO THE FOCUSED -- THAT
YOU MENTIONED WE DO BELIEVE THAT
A PART OF OUR EXPANSION OF THE
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT --
MAKES A DIFFERENCE THERE AND I
WILL SAY ABOUT THAT PART OF THE
PACKAGE WHERE AS MOST OF THE
OTHER ITEMS WITH REGARD TO
SPENDING IN THIS BILL ARE ONE
TIME.
THAT IS AN ON GOING OUT LOCATION
DATA FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS SPLIT BUT PART
OF THAT REALLY IS FOCUSED ON
EXPANDING THAT 4% TAX CREDIT AND
MAKING SURE IT GETS. TO THOSE
FAMILIES BUT ON THE BROADER
POINT AT YOU ARE CORRECT THAT.
THE GOVERNOR DOESN'T BELIEVE
THAT THIS ONE BILL BY ITSELF
WILL SOLVE THE ISSUE AND HE
KNOWS THAT THERE'S SO MUCH MORE
TO DO SO HE NEED MINISTRATION
ARE DEFINITELY LOOKING LATER IN
THE SESSION OVER THE UPCOMING
YEAR. TO CONTINUE TO SEE WHAT
MORE WE CAN DO IN THIS AREA
THERE IS A RECOGNITION THAT THIS
CATEGORY THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
IS THE SOFT SPOT IN THIS.
TRADE HOUSING TRAILER BILL.
IT'S A SOFT SPOT YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THE
TAX CREDITS I THINK IT WAS. TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION CORRECT.
WELL THAT'S THAT'S NICE BUT IT'S
NOT.
IT'S NOT GOING TO PLUG THE DIET
OF THE RISE IN HOMELESSNESS SETS.
NICE BUT IT'S IT'S NOT GOING TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
THEY CERTAINLY MORE TO DO
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
I THINK THERE'S A PACKAGE OF
BILLS GOING TO THE ROCESS ALSO
SERVED A BILL THAT I HOPE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WILL --
HOPEFULLY TAKE ACTUALLY GET TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK YEAH I WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT THE RENT
CONTROL.
BILLS THAT DIED.
ARE GOING TO HAVE A VERY BAD
EFFECT OVER THE NEXT YEAR.
MY OPINION AND SO YOU'RE THE
YOU'RE PREACHING TO THE CHOIR
HERE SIR.
SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN -- THIS IS
BEEN AN INTERESTING I'VE LEARNED
TWO THINGS TODAY -- AS A AS A
NEW CENTER RIGHT AND LEARNED
EARLIER THAT THE CS YOU HAS TO
COME TO THE LEGISLATURE TO GET
PERMISSION.
TO EXPAND THEIR DOCTOR PROGRAMS
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT AS A CS YOU
GRAD.
AND THE SECOND THING I'VE
LEARNED TODAY -- IN A SOONER
MORE LIKE ALLUDED TO IT IS THE
MARIN COUNTY ISSUE -- AND I JUST
WANTED.
TO KIND OF FOR THE OTHER NEW
SENATORS THAT MAYBE ARE FAMILIAR
WITH IT I WAS INTRIGUED BY THIS
AND I'VE GOT A ARTICLEFROM LAST
YEAR BY DAN WALTERS.
AND THE HEADLINE IS MARIN COUNTY
GETS ANOTHER SMUG REPRIEVE.
FROM HOUSING QUOTAS -- AND WHEN
I READ THIS EARLIER TODAY.
THERE WAS A PARTICULAR QUOTE --
THAT'S JUMPED OUT AT ME.
S. ON THE SECOND PAGE IS HOWEVER
WITHOUT WAITING FOR A SCHEDULED
REPORT ON THE COUNTY'S PROGRESS
ON MEETING ITS HOUSING QUOTAS.
THIS FAMILY MEMBER FROM MARIN
PERSUADED LEGISLATIVE LEADERS
LAST MONTH. TO INSERT A MEMBER
THIS IS LAST YEAR -- LEADERS
LAST MONTH TO INSERT INTO A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL SENATE BILL.
ONE OH SIX A BRIEF PASSAGE THAT
EXTENDS MARIN COUNTY'S EXEMPTION.
FROM QUOTAS FOR AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE YEARS UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT BY BEING
ATTACHED TO A TRAILER BILL.
THAT CONTAINED MANY OTHER
PROVISIONS -- RATHER THEN
OFFERED AS A STAND ALONE POLICY
MATTER.
THE MARIN EXEMPTIONS DID A MUCH
BETTER CHANCE AND IS ONE OF MANY
EXAMPLES OF HOW TRAILER BILLS
ARE BLANK.
MISUSED.
AS FOR IN COURT ON THAT IT'S
COUPLE PARAGRAPHS LONG -- THE
ENTIRE ARTICLE AS ONE IF THE NEW
GUY AND GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED
THAT BILL.
AND I'M WONDERING IF THE NEW
GOVERNOR HAS ANY OF AS A PINT ON
THE MARIN COUNTY ISSUE AND AS
YOU'VE ALREADY ANSWER CENTER
MORLOCK THIS PARTICULAR BILL
DOESN'T ADDRESS IT BUT ARE WE
GONNA SEE SOME.
PARITY BETWEEN THE FIFTY SEVEN
OTHER COUNTIES.
AND MARIN COUNTY WHEN IT COMES
TO THESE HOUSING QUOTAS AND THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE IN AND AND
I THINK AS RIGHTLY HAS BEEN
SHARED.
BY A LOT OF PEOPLE ON THIS DIET
ALL OF OUR COUNTIES.
WANT TO ARE TRYING TO BE HELPFUL --
SOMERS WARRANTS IN IF THE NEW
GOVERNOR HAS A HAS A HAS OPINED
ON THIS OR IF THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE MIGHT HAVE AN OPINION.
SO I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT
DIRECTLY AS YOU MENTIONED IT WAS
IT IN A PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
CERTAINLY AS PART OF REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT PROCESS --
WORKING BEING STAKEHOLDERS OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT PROCESS IS
WORKING AS WELL AS POSSIBLE BY
ON THAT SPECIFIC ISSUE.
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANYTHING TO
REPORT BEYOND WHAT'S IN THE BILL
BEFORE YOU TODAY I I THINK SOME
OF THE HOUSING ADVOCATES FROM
LAST YEAR AND I KNOW THERE'S
EVEN A GREAT QUOTE IN THIS
ARTICLE FROM.
CENTER NAILS AND I THINK HE DID
A GOOD JOB OF ANSWERING TO THE
TO THE CONCERN BUT I WOULD HOPE
THE TEN THE GOVERNORS -- WOULD
LISTEN IN THOSE HOUSING
ADVOCATES AND AND TAKE THEIR
CONCERNS -- AT UNDER CAN SPOT
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE DOUBLED BACK
TO SEVEN TO REQUIRE IF ANYONE
ELSE WHO HASN'T PULLED THE
QUESTION YET HAVE -- ONE C. NINE
SIR TO REQUIRE FOLLOWED BY MORE
LOCK TO REQUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH AT MADAM CHAIR AND I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF.
LOOK I I GET THAT MARIN COUNTY
IS A IS A FINE PUNCHING BAG FOR
MANY IN THIS LEGISLATURE BUT I'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO CLARIFY WHAT
EXACTLY WAS IN THE BUDGET.
HERE AT THREE YEARS AGO.
NUMBER ONE THERE IS NO EXEMPTION
IS BASED OFF OF DENSITY SO MARIN
COUNTY WAS LABELED AS AN URBAN
COUNTY IT IS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND FOLKS. TO A FIFTY
THOUSAND TOTAL POPULATION.
SO WHAT THE BUDGET DID IT WAS
BASED OFF A DENSITY HOW MANY
HOURS PER ACRE.
THE COUNTY WILL BUILD IN THE
CITIES WITHIN THE COUNTY WOULD
BUILD.
SO RATHER THAN LABELING.
MARIN COUNTY AS URBAN.
IT WAS RE CATEGORIES TO SUBURBAN.
GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF A SUBURBAN
COUNTY CINEMA WITH.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND SAN MATTEO
WAS.
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND AGAIN
I'D LIKE TO REPEAT BRING COUNTY
HAS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE CHARACTERIZED AS IN
FORMALLY.
IN IN THE LAW AS URBAN.
SO WHAT THE BILL DID. EIGHT
TRANSITION FROM AN URBAN OUNTY
TO SUBURBAN COUNTY THERE WAS NO
EXEMPTION THANKS DAVID THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
PRESHEAF THAT CENTER MORE LAW.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I KNOW
THAT IT'S DIFFICULT TO DISCUSS
ONGOING LITIGATION -- BUT WE'VE
ALREADY.
MADE AN EXAMPLE OF THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND I'M JUST
KIND OF CURIOUS NOW THAT YOU
HAVE A PROCESS FORMAL PROCESS
THAT YOU'RE.
PROPOSING -- DO YOU -- INTEND TO
CONTINUE WITH THIS CASE -- OR DO
YOU PLAN ON REBOOTING AND
TREATING THEM THE SAME AS AS THE
PROPOSED POLICY.
SO I CANNOT DISCUSS ONGOING
LITIGATION AS YOU -- PRESUMED --
I WILL SAY YOU KNOW WHAT -- EVEN
WITH THAT LAWSUIT WHEN THAT
LAWSUIT WAS FILED -- THE
GOVERNOR MADE IT CLEAR THAT I
BELIEVE WAS FOR IT WAS MORE THAN
FORTY JURISDICTIONS THAT WEREN'T
CURRENTLY IN COMPLIANCE.
HIS GOAL BEING RESTRICTIONS
GOALS NOT TO FILE A BUNCH OF
LAWSUITS IT'S TO BRING THESE
JURISDICTIONS INTO COMPLIANCE
AND UNDER THE PROCESS OUTLINED
IN THIS BILL.
IF THE COURT DETERMINES THAT TO
SENATOR STERN'S POINT THAT --
THE JURISDICTION IS IN
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE DAN AND
NONE OF THESE REMEDIES WILL
APPLY AFTER THAT FACT.
SO.
THIS PROCESS THIS BILL BEFORE
YOU MAKE SOME CHANGES TO THE
REMEDIES -- BUT THE UNDERLYING
LAW THAT WE HOPE AND EXPECT
JURISDICTIONS TO COMPLY WITH THE
STILL THE SAME.
I BELIEVE THAT TO THE READER
REQUIREMENTS FOR HUNTINGTON
BEACH WERE IN THE MID THIRTEEN
HUNDREDS AND THEY HAD ALREADY.
CONSTRUCTED SOME NINE HUNDRED
UNITS THAT THAT KIND OF PUT THEM
SOMEWHERE.
ALONG THE WAY.
THE CITY NEXT DOOR ONLY REQUIRES
EIGHTY SIX UNITS FOR COMPLIANCE
FARINA.
SO THE THIRD RING INTERESTING
DISPARITIES ARE I JUST WANT TO
BRING THAT UP FOR THE RECORD
THAT WE'VE GOT TO SEE THAT
ACTUALLY.
HAS HAS SOME MOVEMENT IN IN
TRYING TO COMPLY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VENTURE
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NICOLO TO LIVE HERE IN
THE UP AFTER THE OAKLAND MAYOR
STRONG SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SPECIALLY ON SINCE
FUNDING.
REALLY WANTED THANK AN ECHO WHAT
SENATOR SKINNER SAID WITH REGARD
TO EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
LOOKING FOR THAT DISCUSSION THE
VERY VALUABLE TO FOR TOOL FOR US
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS.
JENNIFER SPOKE ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL SPECIFICALLY THE PROVISIONS
RELATED TO PLANNING -- AND
FINALLY ENFORCING THE STATE'S
HOUSING LAW IT'S THE FIRST UP WE
NEED IN ORDER TO GET THE
PRODUCTION THAT WE NEED TO PLAN
FIRST THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR HOMELESS.
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION AND
ESPECIALLY THE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION
DIRECTLY THE COUNTIES COUNTIES
AS YOU KNOW OR THE PROVIDERS OF
THE STATE'S SAFETY NET SERVICES.
SO WE THINK THEY'RE VERY WELL
POSITIONED TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
THE GAPS ARE AND TO HELP
ALLEVIATE THAT LEVY ATE THEM AND
REALLY TACKLE THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS WE ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN IN PHILLY
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANTS.
ESPECIALLY THE PROVISIONS IN THE
BILL THAT HELP SMALLER MORE
RURAL AREAS INCLUDING
UNINCORPORATED AREAS ACCESS THE
FUNDING.
AND FINALLY WHILE WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PRECEDENT
SETTING NATURE OF THE HOUSING
ELEMENT ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS
WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THAT ASPECT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY BORDER SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF THE HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING.
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S LEGISLATURES
PROPOSALS AS WELL AS ALL OF THE
STAFF WORK.
IN PARTICULAR ORANGE COUNTY IS
ADDITIONALLY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
LOCAL HOUSING TRUST LANGUAGE
ALLOWING US BE TOO AS A LOCAL
MATCH.
AND A SAN BERNADINO COUNTY WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU.
FOR PROVIDING FUNDING FOR BOTH
COUNTIES AND CEO SEES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MARTHA GROW RPRESENTING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND ALSO FOR THE ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GOING TO COUNTIES AS THE
SEC MENTIONED.
WE ARE VERY WELL AWARE OF THE
GAPS AND ALSO BRIDGING THOSE
GAPS WITH THE COUNTY SERVICE --
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THAT IS
NEEDED ALSO APPRECIATIVE AND HOW
IT BUILDS UPON ALL THE OTHER
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS -- POVERTY
ENDING POVERTY LOT OF THESE ARE
FAMILIES IN SO THIS IS GOING TO
HELP BRIDGE THOSE EFFORTS --
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS --
MENTIONED HERE ABOUT PREVENTING
HOMELESSNESS AS YOU KNOW THE WE
HAVE A FEW BILLS THAT -- WE ARE
SPONSORING -- ONE SB THREE
TWENTY NINE AND A FEW OTHER
BILLS THAT WERE SUPPORTING -- TO
PREVENT -- HOMELESSNESS IN
PREVENTING INFECTIONS AND THOSE
pWE'RE HAVING TO DEAL WITH THE
THE HIGHER NUMBERS THAT WERE
HAVING TO DEAL WITH AS A RESULT
OF THAT. TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU AS WE MOVE FORWARD ON
ANY -- LANGUAGE THAT -- IS
PROPOSED TO BE CHANGED AS WE
HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE WITH
UNLESS ANGELES COUNTY AND ALSO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU AND
I WELCOME YOU TO COME -- TO
VISIT OUR OUR COUNTY TO LOOK AT
WHAT WE'RE DOING TO PREVENT
HOMELESS IN ADDRESSING ALL THIS
IS ON THE STREETS THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GENE
HEARST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA --
IS SIMILAR TO MY COLLEAGUES WERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
ALLOCATIONS RICK.
WITH REGARDS TO HOMELESSNESS --
PLANNING AND INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS AS WELL WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU
ON THESE IMPORTANT ISSUE.
THANK YOU FINAL WITNESS AT
CANNES LAWYERS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YEARS
AND SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
HOMELESS AND FUNDING AND
APPRECIATE THE SET ASIDE FOR
YEARS SPECIFICALLY I WOULD NOTE
AND THE DEFINITION FOR YOUTH
ESPECIALLY IT INCLUDES THOSE
YOUTH YOUR COUCH SURFING SO WE
CAN REALLY ADDRESS.
THE ONES WHO ARE OUTSIDE THAT
HAD RESTRICTED DEFINITION -- AND
APPRECIATE THE SYSTEMS PLANNING
WORKS WERE WE KNOW WHERE THE
GAPS ARE FOR YOU.
I'M BECAUSE 80% AT THE LHASA
TWENTY EIGHTEEN POINT COUNT WERE
AND SHELTERED SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
THANK YOU SEE NO FOR THE
WITNESSES AT THE FAR DOES
WOULDN'T MIND CALLING B. AND P.
COMMITTEE I THINK THAT'S WHERE.
SENATOR PANY S. LET THEM KNOW
THAT WE'RE ABOUT TO TAKE THE
ROLE.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL IF YOU WANT TO WIN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS MITCHELL
HI THE CHILL I NIELSEN.
WILSON ON A BELL.
CAPOEIRA CAREER I'D DOLLY.
KELLY I OR TOTO.
OR TOTAL I JONES.
JONES I'D LEYBA MCGUIRE MINING
MONEY NINE MORE LUCK.
MORE LOOK I'D PAN ROSS.
I SKINNER SKINNER ON A STERN
STERN ICE DOWN STONE I BERG
AMBERG IOWA KASKI.
WHY BECAUSE THE I?
HOLD THE BALL.
ALL OPEN FOR ABOUT FIVE MINUTES
TO LOVE THE MEMBERS TO COME IN
AT ON THANK YOU
.
I LIKE THE CALL THE ACTIVE
MEMBERS PLEASE.
LABOR.
MCGUIRE PAN [inaudible]
CAN I
WITH A VOTE OF FIFTEEN TO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES AND
BUDGET COMMITTEE STANDS
ADJOURNED